ages have passed since the gods walked  among us before the fury swept over our  land before the war the divided us for  eternity  you know fit to be king it's my turn now  set to taken over Egypt and enslaved its  people  one God can save us but not without his  eyes stealing from a god only a madman  would try such a thing where do you  suppose we could find someone so mad I  have something set up for me we need  your help the world  so how do we stop him try to keep up  you know what's waiting that has an army  behind him  bow before me or die  I don't make that mistake  is that the storm sets hundreds riding  pets we should run run we mortals do it  all the time  why are you here to save all people can  we trust him